The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: --not of the
vindictive sort.
You skip class, you've skipped
a lot of important stuff.
But I'll get you on the
quiz, that's all.
Kidding aside, there were
a number of things
that I passed out.
I think nobody needs a set
of problem set number 13.
That was the one that had
something on symmetry
constraints and working with
second-rank tensors.
If anybody missed that, you
can see me during break.
Some people, I think, missed
problem set 14.
And that's the one where you
are invited to diagonalize
some tensors, either using
the method of successive
approximations or the direct
diagonalization-
by-an-eigenvalue procedure.
Anybody need one of that?
And I'm sure that nobody has a
copy of problem set number 15,
which deals with
piezoelectricity.
And I know you don't
have it, because
I just put it together.
So I'd like to hand it out and
invite you to explore things
that deal with third-rank
tensors.
And I hope that, even though
doing the problem sets is
optional, particularly at this
juncture in the semester when
things have come to a set
of successive crunches.
But if you don't know how to
do it, for goodness' sakes,
come see me.
Or raise it in our next class.
You know, some question like,
I haven't the foggiest idea
how to do problem number two.
Could you say a little bit
about that, please?
And I'd be happy to oblige.
All right.
I will have for you next time
the quizzes and also all the
problem sets which will
have been turned
in up to that point.
And what I spent my time doing
instead is writing out notes
for those people who missed
the last lecture, and also
notes covering what we're
going to do today.
Because it is very exquisitely
intensive, algebraically.
It's not hard, but there are a
lot of variables with a lot of
subscripts.
So let me pass this around.
I'll split it up into packs.
These are notes on some basic
relations in electromagnetism
which you may or may
not have forgotten.
Take one off the top.
And it's coming at you from
either side, so you're going
to pass it back.
And the notes also cover
everything that we're going to
do on piezoelectricity.
Most of it will take
place today.
And I can zip along a little
more rapidly if you
have notes to follow.
I would like to ask you when you
get a set of the notes--
I could really kick myself--
the introductory discussion
reminds you of the definition
of a dipole.
And down in the middle of the
page, on the cover sheet, two
different types of
polarizability are defined.
And one of them involves the
separation of charge on an
individual atom.
And that is called, quite
appropriately, the electronic
polarizability because it
involves polarization of the
electrons and protons on
the individual atoms.
And then there's another type of
induced dipole moment that
comes when the structure
is ionic.
And then an electric field will
pull positive ions in one
direction and negative ions
in the opposite direction.
And that is very often referred
to as the ionic
polarizability.
And it's easy to keep
them straight.
One involves electrons,
which all atoms have.
The other involves ions.
And not all structures and
materials have ions.
So the second one is unique
to ionic structures.
And then, these are sometimes
also referred to as the
dielectric polarizability.
And I meant to purge that
from the notes.
And as I put this together to
xerox it, I grabbed the
uncorrected sheet.
So please, just below you see
the displaced positive and
negative ion on the middle
of the page, cross out
"dielectric" polarizability.
And change that to "ionic"
polarizability.
And I didn't catch that.
There's one other little typo
as we go partway through.
In any case, we'll talk about
third-rank tensor properties.
We'll introduce some other
ones other than
piezoelectricity later on.
But piezoelectricity is one of
the primary examples of a
third-rank tensor property.
And it's one that has a lot of
applications in devices--
pressure sensors, audio
equipment, electronic devices.
It's a very important property
in terms of devices and
present-day technology.
But there are others.
And we'll cover those
in due course.
Some of them are
rather exotic.
OK.
But to review these basic
concepts in electromagnetism,
we remind you again of the
definition of a dipole.
We mentioned this last time.
But to quickly review, a dipole
is a pair of charges of
opposite sign but equal
magnitude, separated by a
separation, d.
And then one defines a dipole
moment, which has a vector
character, as the product
of one of the charges of
magnitude, q.
And the vector that separates
the two charges in the sense
of the vector is defined as
going from the negative charge
and pointing towards the
positive charge.
It's purely a definition.
But the reason it's convenient
is that the vector sense and
the product of charge and
separation comes up again and
again in all sorts of
problems, among them
definition of the piezoelectric
effects.
Also a dipole in an electric
field is going to experience a
torque because the electric
field will pull on the
positive charge in the
same direction.
It will pull on the negative
charge in the opposite
direction from the field.
And that's going to create a
torque on this little gizmo.
OK.
Now it's important, too--
and interesting to note-- that
there are three different
kinds of dipole moments.
There are some molecules--
and water is the primary
example.
Water has seen an asymmetrical
arrangement of hydrogen,
relative to the oxygen ion to
which they are connected.
And that gives water a permanent
dipole moment, which
is what makes water such
a darn good solvent.
And its ability to dissolve
primordial juices probably
accounts for our fact,
intelligent design
notwithstanding, of why
we are here today.
On the other hand, dipoles, as
I was just saying, can be
induced when you impose an
electric field on matter.
And these are of two kinds.
One is the dipole moment
that is induced on
an individual atom.
And that results in displacement
of the positive
nucleus relative to the negative
electron shell.
It's found that the dipole
moment is proportional to the
magnitude of the
electric field.
And the proportionality
constant, alpha, is called the
polarizability.
And for an individual atom, as
I said a moment ago, it's
defined as the electronic
polarizability.
We write it as a scalar
quantity, but actually, by now
you're probably sensitized to
being a little bit skeptical
when things that relate
to vectors are
described as a scalar.
And in fact, the electronic
polarizability is not a
scalar, it's a tensor.
And one should really write that
the i-th component of the
dipole moment is given by
alpha i,j times the j-th
component of the
electric field.
Second type of induced dipole
moment involves, again as we
said a moment ago, the effect of
imposing an electric field
on an ionic structure.
And again, the field will pull
the positive ions in one
direction and negative
ions in the other.
And here quite clearly, if
this pair of ions is in a
structure, and that structure
has some symmetry, we really
have to consider this second
origin to induce dipole
moments as a tensor.
And this is referred to as
the ionic polarizability.
So both of these types of dipole
moments will be present
in matter, in general.
The relative importance of each
depends on whether the
electric field is a static
field or an oscillatory
electric field.
And then the frequency
dependence of these two
polarizabilities has a
consequence on the magnitude
for fields of different
frequencies.
And not surprisingly, the
ability of the ions in the
structure to polarize is
going to poop out with
high-frequency electric fields
a lot quicker than just the
displacement of the
light electrons
about a positive nucleus.
So there is a frequency
dependence of the net
polarizability.
We won't go into that.
But just keep in mind that at
very high-frequency electric
fields, the ionic polarizability
will damp out.
OK.
Then we went through a rather
simplified but amusing model
for the electronic
polarizability.
And there's some rather severe
assumptions that are made.
But making those assumptions
let's you get a rigorous
result, which tells you
something about the electronic
polarizability.
So we model the electron
distribution on the atom as a
uniform charge density in a
distribution that goes up to
some radius, r, and
then quits.
So there's a sharp cutoff to the
distribution of electrons,
which is obviously ridiculous.
You know there are a collection
of wave functions
that give you charge
probabilities that tail off
slowly to large distances,
getting progressively smaller
and smaller.
So this is not terribly
realistic.
And then the other thing we
assume to make this model,
something that we can solve
exactly, is that the nucleus
and the electron distribution
displace as units.
In other words, we start with
a sphere of electrons, the
center displaces, but it stays
a sphere of uniformly
distributed electrons.
And then having made those
assumptions and having lost
any credibility for the model,
if we carry through to see
what the model predicts, it's
rather interesting.
We use a fact, again, known
to freshman and sophomore
students of electromagnetism,
that a charge inside of a
uniform distribution of charge
experiences no force.
And that's surprising, but it's
something that you are
very often invited to
do on problem sets.
So therefore, if the center of
the electron distribution is
displaced from the nucleus,
then the restoring force
between the electron sphere and
the nucleus is simply the
coulombic force between a
nucleus of charge plus ze, and
a fraction of the total number
of electrons, namely that
fraction of the electrons which
are contained within a
sphere that has a radius equal
to the displacement.
And that geometry and that
algebra's carried out for you
on the bottom of
the first page.
If you set that up and ask what
the dipole moment will
be, it comes out beautifully
simple.
It comes out to be equal to
whatever proportionality
constant you use in
Coulomb's law.
I use rationalized MKS units
from force of habit.
So there's a 4 pi epsilon 0 in
there, then times the cube of
the radius of the electron
distribution, times the
electric field.
So the two items of note that
come out of this simplified
treatment is first of all, the
induced dipole moment is
proportional to the applied
electric field, which is what
we assumed.
And so therefore, the
polarizability, which is the
quantity that relates the dipole
moment to the magnitude
of the field, is a constant.
And it turns out to be
equal to 4 pi epsilon
0, times the radius.
So not only does this tell
us that the electronic
polarizability is something that
relates dipole moment in
direct proportion to the
magnitude of the field.
And secondly, the electronic
polarizability involves the
radius of the charge
distribution, cubed.
And even on a qualitative basis,
this is interesting.
It tells you that
high-atomic-number, big, fat
ions are going to have a very,
very large polarizability.
And things way down in the
periodic table, like beryllium
and lithium, and other low-z
atoms, are going to be tough
little nuts that don't display
much polarization at all.
And in point of fact, several
individuals have tabulated
empirical sets of electronic
polarizabilities.
One of the earliest ones are
the so-called TKS values
published a long time ago
by Tessman, Kahn,
and "Wild Bill" Shockley.
And I give you the reference
to those.
There is another set of values
that were assembled by a
fellow at DuPont named
Bob Shannon.
And I'll give you a citation
to those values.
But in any case, if you look at
these values, you find that
the cation that has highest
electronic polarizability is
thallium, way down on the bottom
of the periodic table,
next to lead.
And that's just a big, fat,
flabby atom that can be
deformed very, very easily.
How do you get these
polarizabilities?
Well, the equations at the
bottom of page two-- which we
won't make any use of but,
nevertheless, will tell you
where they come from--
there's a relation between the
square of the index of
refraction and the sum of the
polarizabilities of the
individual species, times the
number of those species per
unit volume.
And that is something that's
called the Lorentz-Lorenz
equation, equation.
I can't resist saying
everything
twice, Lorenz and Lorentz.
You can put this in another
form that involves the
molecular weight of a molecular
structure and the
polarizability per molecule.
It's the same equation, but
for organic compounds.
It's a useful form.
And it turns out that the
dielectric constant of the
material is directly related to
the square of the index of
refraction.
So you can write those two
equations in terms of either
the dielectric constant or
the index of refraction.
And if you substitute dielectric
constant in place
of n squared in those
equations, the
equations get new names.
And they're not called the
Lorentz-Lorenz equation, equations.
They're called the
Clausius-Mossotti equations,
which shows you that sometimes
fame and immortality can be
gained simply by a trivial
substitution of variables.
Nice to keep in mind if you can
find something like that.
Finally, we don't see
dipole moments on
individual atoms or molecules.
We see evidence of polarization
in bulk.
And on page three is a little
model that reminds you of what
the polarization of
a material is.
And that's defined as
simply the dipole
moment per unit volume.
And that's represented
by a capital P rather
than a small p.
And this is also a
vector quantity.
And we can see how this is
related to the individual
dipole moments in the solid by
dividing the solid up into
individual cells.
And I use the term of
"cell" loosely.
Is this a unit cell?
Is this a box around
each of the atoms?
It really doesn't matter.
Because all of these little
dipoles on the individual unit
cells are packed together back
to front in the solid.
So internally, the negative
end of one induced dipole
moment is always adjacent to
the positive end of the
neighboring dipole moment.
And everything cancels out
internally, except for the two
surfaces of the solid.
So macroscopically, if you
impose an electric field and
it induces dipole moments, what
happens is you see that
there is a charge on
the surface of
the piece of material.
And that is a real charge.
It's a bound charge.
You can't draw that charge
off as a current.
Because the minute you reduce
and eliminate the electric
field, those dipoles
disappear.
And the charges all go back
to where they came from.
So this is the thing that keeps
the exact model that we
use for one of the cells in the
solid [INAUDIBLE] of no
importance whatsoever.
You could say that the dipole
moment on each atom is the
charge times the separation
of the positive
and negative charge.
And qi is the induced charge.
The number of cells per unit
volume, if we say that they're
little cubes of the same edge
length, delta, is unit volume
one divided by the volume
per cell, which
will be delta cubed.
And the dipole moment per unit
volume is the number of cells
per unit volume times the
polarization on each.
And you find that everything
drops out.
And the polarization indeed
turns out to be equal to
induced charge per unit area,
whether that's induced charge
per unit area of one of our
cells or on a square
centimeter of material.
So polarization, dipole moment
per unit volume is numerically
equal to, and physically
equivalent to, an induced
charge per unit area.
OK.
So much for freshman
electromagnetism in fast forward.
And now I'd like to turn to
something that involves
tensors and materials.
As I mentioned a moment ago,
piezoelectricity, literally
"pressure electricity," is a
very technologically important
property, useful property, but
also provides a nice example
of a tensor property that has
to be defined in terms of a
sensor of third rank.
There are a number of different
piezoelectric effects.
The first one is the so-called
direct piezoelectric effect.
And it refers to the fact that
if you subject a material to
an applied stress, it will
develop a surface charge.
Remove the applied stress, the
surface charge goes away.
The surface charge can be
described in terms of a
polarization, a dipole moment
per unit volume.
And it will be in direct
proportion to a stress
tensor sigma j,k.
And so what we'll assume--
and this is an assumption.
And it's followed, except for
very extreme conditions, that
each component of the
polarization, p sub i, is
given by a linear combination
of every one of the nine
elements of stress, sigma i,j.
Oops, not i,j.
I have to use a different
index.
I'm used to writing i,j.
So each component of the
polarization, where i ranges
from 1 to 3, is given by a
linear combination of all nine
of the elements of stress,
sigma j,k.
And the proportionality
constants, di,j,k, are known
as the piezoelectric moduli.
And this is called the direct
piezoelectric effect.
OK.
That's simply an assumption
that the polarization is
proportional to the
applied stress.
We know that stress,
however, is a field
tensor of second rank.
We know that the polarization
has the character of a vector,
charge times the length.
We know how second-rank
tensors transform.
We know how first-rank
And therefore, knowing that,
we can say that the
coefficients, the array of
coefficients, di,j,k, will
transform like a third-rank
tensor.
And therefore they
are a tensor.
So we will have three components
of polarization.
And we will have nine components
of stress.
And so there will be 27
piezoelectric moduli, di,j,k.
So things go up rapidly
in terms of number of
coefficients as the rank
of a tensor increases.
Now let's take a look at the
nature of these equations.
We'll have, for example, the x1
component of P being given
by d1,1,1 times the element
of stress sigma 1,1.
The next term will be d1,2,2
times sigma 2,2.
I'm putting down the tensor
components first.
But this is just an equation.
I can write the terms
in any order.
Next will be a d1,3,3
times sigma 3,3.
And the next one would be a
d1,2,3 times a shear component
of stress sigma 2,3
and other terms.
I don't want to write out
all nine of them.
Because I think I have written
enough to make my point.
The point is that the value
of i is always tied to the
component of the resulting
vector that we're defining.
But the second pair of
subscripts, j and k, always go
together as an unseparable pair
with the component of
stress that they modify.
So the 1,1 here goes
with the 1,1.
The 2,2 goes with the 2,2.
The 3,3 goes with the 3,3.
So why in the world, if they're
always going to go
together, do we have to use
two indices to define the
piezoelectric moduli?
Why don't we use a
single symbol?
Well, there is a good reason
for not doing it.
But we'll issue that
caveat later on.
We could use an a, a b, and a c,
or an alpha or a beta or a
gamma, or some other
esoteric symbol.
But what makes sense since we're
using Arabic numerals to
represent subscripts, let's
write the pair of indices in
terms of an index that's related
to the stress tensor,
which is sigma 1,1;
sigma 2,2; sigma--
whoops.
Sigma 1,2; sigma 1,3.
And then comes sigma 2,1; sigma
2,2; sigma 2,3; sigma
3,1; sigma 3,2; sigma 3,3.
We know that this is
a symmetric tensor.
So these off-diagonal
terms are always
equal to one another.
So we're numerically going
to have to enter
each of those twice.
So to define a single index
that represents the
components of stress.
And I'll describe it in this
fashion so you can remember,
as a mnemonic device, what
makes this work.
We'll go down the main diagonal
of the stress tensor,
this fashion.
And then having reached the
bottom, we'll go up along the
right-hand side and then jog
over to the left to pick up
the last term.
And we'll define a number
associated with these indices
that goes in the form 1 to 2,
to 3, to 4, to 5, to 6.
So we'll just use these three
integers, ranging from 1 to 6,
to represent pairs of integers
in the stress tensor.
So things tidy up quite
nicely then.
This would be P1 is d1,1 times
sigma 1; plus d1,2 times sigma
2; plus d1,3 times sigma 3;
plus d1,4 times sigma 4.
And now, uh-oh, Houston.
We've got a problem.
Because there's another
term in here that is
d1,3,2 times sigma 3,2.
And sigma 3,2 is required,
because the stress tensor is
symmetric, to be numerically
equal to sigma 2,3.
So this is really d1,2,3
times sigma 2,3.
And then we've got a d1,3,2
times a sigma 3,2.
I know that this is
equal to this.
But is there any reason d1,2,3
has to be equal to d1,3,2?
I can't see any reason why.
OK.
Let me confide in you that,
yes, they are equal.
But we can't show it or claim it
on the basis of what we've
got before us right now.
It's going to come later.
But we can show that
they are equal.
OK.
But equal or not, this means
we'll have a term d1,4 sigma
4, and we're going to get
it in there twice.
So when the subscripts go up to
4, we're going to get a 2
out in front.
And then we'll get for the term
sigma 1,3 and 3,1 we'll
have a d1,5 times a sigma 5.
This would be sigma 1,3.
And then we'd have another
d1,5 for sigma 5 again.
And this would be sigma 3,1.
So what are we going to do?
We're going to say, well, it's
nice we're getting rid of an
unneeded subscript.
P1 is the d1,1 times sigma 1;
plus d1,2 times sigma 2; plus
d1,3 times sigma 3.
Are we then going to say 2 d1,4
times sigma four, and say
that the coefficient here
is di,j when i is
equal to 1, 2, 3.
But the coefficient is 2 di,j
when j is 4, 5, or 6?
Hell of a matrix
that would be.
That's going to be a bother.
Since it doesn't seem that
we can measure these two
coefficients, d1,2,3 and d1,3,2,
independently anyhow,
let's just write our relation in
reduced subscripts with the
two added together as
the element d1,4.
So we are going to define d1,4
equals d1,3,2 plus d1,2,3.
So that's a definition.
And d1,5 will be defined as the
sum of d1,1,3 plus d1,3,1.
And we're going to define
d1,6, finally,
as d1,1,2 plus d1,2,1.
OK.
So if we do that, then and only
then are we entitled to
write a nice, simple, compact
little nugget that says that
in our redefined form,
Pi is equal to di,j
times sigma of j.
And i goes from 1 to 3, and
j goes from 1 to 6.
And this is kind of
a neat compact,
easily managed outcome.
So the moral of this story is,
I like to think, is you can
have your cake if
you eat its 2.
Oh come on, this is a
tough, tough crowd.
You're just all worn out
from the MRS meeting.
That'll do it to anybody.
So why do we worry about the
fact that to the direct
piezoelectric effect should
be a third-rank tensor?
The answer, my friends, is
that this is no longer a
tensor relationship.
It's a matrix relationship.
A tensor is a matrix, but it's
a matrix with a difference.
It's a matrix for which a law of
transformation is defined,
if you change axes.
There's no such law defined
for the di,j's.
So they qualify as a matrix,
but they are not a tensor.
So to attempt to say-- as you
might be inclined to do when
we raise the issue of what the
symmetry restrictions are on
these tensors--
if you attempt to say, well, I'm
going to find d2,1 prime.
And that's going to be
c2,i c1,j times di,j.
Wrong.
You go down in flames because
that's just nonsense.
That's just nonsense.
So this is a matrix relation.
And if you want to do exercises
such as slice a
piezoelectric wafer out of a
piece of quartz, and then
having done so, refer the
properties to axes taken along
those edges of the plate that
you've cut, you've got to-- in
order to find the piezoelectric
moduli for that
plate in that new coordinate
system--
you've got to be prepared always
to go back to the full
tensor notation.
If you want to derive symmetry
restrictions, which we're
going to do whether you
want to or not--
but we won't do them
exhaustively--
you've got to go from this
matrix notation back to the
full three-subscript
tensor notation.
OK?
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Couldn't you extend c
sub i,k's to be [? 3,6's ?]
and extend most others
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
No, if we would write all
these down, we'd have--
I don't know if that's what
you're asking-- but we'd have
P1 is equal to d1,j times sigma
sub j; P2 is equal to
d2,j sigma sub j; and
P3 is equal to d3,j
times sigma sub j.
So I just did that for the
line with i equal to 1,
because I was too lazy to write
down all three relations.
Is that what you're asking?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm saying you
could have a transformation
model if you were to extend a
c sub i,j matrix to be 3,6.
PROFESSOR: No.
It just won't do it.
I mean, think of what
these indices are.
They're 1, 2, and 3 standing for
the x1 direction, the x2
direction, the x3 direction.
What's the x5 direction?
It's just not defined.
Good try, but you just
can't do it.
AUDIENCE: I'll think of
something next time.
PROFESSOR: Oh, I'm
sure you will.
Whether it will work
or not is an
absolutely different question.
OK.
So beware.
Do not try to transform
tensors of third rank
expressed with two subscripts
to other coordinate systems.
All right.
What I would like to do now,
then, is to examine the
symmetry restrictions that are
imposed on a third-rank tensor
by crystallographic symmetry.
And these are embedded in
the notes that you have.
But it's going to
be bothersome to
leaf through those.
So I separated out the
pages separately.
And I'm going to look at a few
transformations so that you
can see how they work, and then
point out some very, very
curious consequences of this,
which are non-intuitive.
So first of all, how
would we do it?
If we want to get the form
of di,j, the matrix for--
let's do a very, very
simple one.
Well, let's do one that we did
last time, for those who were
here, for inversion.
For inversion, the direction
cosine scheme
is c1,1, 0; 0, 0--
I'm sorry.
For 1 bar, the transformation
of axes is c1,1, 0, 0; 0,
c2,2, 0; 0, 0, c3,3.
So we'll take di,j, change it
to the full three-subscript
notation, di,j,k.
And the law for transformation
of the third-rank tensor is
di,j,k prime is equal to ci,
capital I; cj, capital J; ck,
capital K; times d, capital I,
capital J, capital K. We've
not done this much.
But we've mentioned quite some
time ago that this is the way
a third-rank tensor would
transform element by element.
The only terms that are non-zero
in this array, when
the symmetry transformation
is inversion--
where x1, x2, x3 goes to minus
x1, minus x2, minus x3--
is whatever i is, minus
1; whatever j is--
only the diagonal terms
are there, and
they're all minus 1--
whatever k is, it's going to
be minus 1, times di,j,k.
So we find that for inversion,
di,j,k prime is always,
regardless of what the three
indices are, is going to be
minus di,j,k.
And if inversion is a symmetry
operation which the crystal
possesses, we're demanding that
the transform index be
identical to the
original index.
But there's a minus
sign in there.
So we can say that every
single element
vanishes, has to vanish.
So any crystal that has
inversion in it is not going
to be able to display the
piezoelectric effect or any
other third-rank tensor
property.
The electro-optic effect,
piezoresistance, and there are
a whole slew of them, which are
examined for you in part
on this sheet.
One third-rank tensor property
is the direct piezoelectric
effect, which we've been
discussing as our example.
There is something called the
converse piezoelectric effect,
which describes the phenomenon
where an applied electric
field creates a strain.
So the direct effect is you
[? scush ?] your material, you
develop charge.
The converse piezoelectric
effect says if you apply an
electric field that's going to
move the atoms around and
induce polarizations, you are
going to create a strain.
And the absolutely mind-boggling
thing is that
the same array of 3 by 9
coefficients describe both the
direct piezoelectric effect
and the converse
piezoelectric effect.
So in one relation, we have
that each component of
polarization is di,j,k times the
nine elements of stress.
And that means we have to write
three equations in nine
variables, the elements
of stress.
And the converse piezoelectric
effect, we're
developing a strain.
And there are, therefore,
nine elements of strain.
And we're applying a vector,
e sub i, a field.
So there are three components
of that vector.
27 elements, 3 times 9.
27 elements, 9 times 3.
So both of these are
third-rank tensors.
Strain transforms like
a second-rank tensor.
Field vectors transform like
a first-rank tensor.
Therefore, the coefficients
are elements of
a third-rank tensor.
But what boggles the mind is
that the same 27 numbers
describe these two seemingly
disparate phenomena.
You don't prove this
by symmetry.
You don't prove this by the
nature of stress and strain.
This hinges on the thermodynamic
argument, which
I'm not going to go into.
But what you do if you're
willing to stretch tensor
notation a little bit--
you can't have a 3 by 9 array
when you've got a tensor of
second rank on the left and
a vector on the right.
You have to write this in this
fashion, that di,j,k times ei
gives you the element of
strain, epsilon j,k.
And that's not proper
tensor notation.
But we're not going
to quibble.
Because if you allow this
little departure from
convention, then you can
write both the converse
piezoelectric effect and the
direct piezoelectric effect in
terms of the same matrix.
But again, that is not
intuitively obvious.
It does not have
to be the case.
And it hinges on an argument
in thermodynamics.
Some other examples of
piezoelectric relations that
I've mentioned in the notes.
If you apply a stress and you
get a polarization, that
stress produces a strain.
So you also have to get a
polarization if you're
applying a stress, and write
it in terms of the strain
that's produced.
Similarly, if you apply an
electric field and it produces
a strain, the crystal must
be in a state of stress.
So there must be relation
between stress and applied
electric field, which will also
be a third-rank tensor.
Those two relations are
represented by coefficients
given the symbol e.
And again, the same array
of 27 elements
describes both effects.
And these are not dignified
with any special names.
They're just tensor relations
that have to be true because
of the fact that stress
and strain are
coupled by elastic relations.
Not surprisingly, then, the
coefficients e must somehow
involve the piezoelectric moduli
di,j and the elastic
properties of the material.
Another effect which is a very
interesting one is the
electro-optic effect.
If you apply an electric field
to a material, you change the
birefringence of the field.
The birefringence is defined as
the difference in index of
refraction for light polarized
in two orthogonal directions.
Another tensor effect-- and I'll
give you a note defining
the terms next time we meet--
there is a piezoresistive
effect, which you don't see
talked about very much.
But that's a property that
Texas Instruments was
interested in at one time.
And I have a set of sheets
defining those relations that
the presenter of a paper
at a meeting, one time,
kindly gave to me.
OK.
So what other symmetry
restrictions are there?
Having shown that inversion will
not permit any third-rank
tensor property, we have gone
from 32 point groups, lost
interest in the 11
centrosymmetric point groups.
And so there are only 21
piezoelectric point groups.
And the way we would plod
through all 21 of them would
be to simply define, starting
with a twofold axis.
Let's say a twofold axis
parallel to x3 would
correspond to a change of axes
ci,j that describes the new
axes in terms of the original
ones that consisted of minus
1, 0, 0; 0, minus
1, 0; 0, 0, 1.
So if we look at an element in
the piezoelectric matrix--
something like d1,6--
d1,6 actually corresponds
in tensor notation
to d1,3,2 plus d1,2,3.
And d1,3,2 prime is going to be
c1,i c3,j c2,k times all of
the original tensor
elements di,j,k.
The only term of the form
ci, something that
is non-zero is c,1,1.
And that has a value, minus 1.
The only term of the form
c3, something which
is non-zero is c3,3.
And that turns out
to be plus 1.
c2, something, the only form
that's non-zero is c2,2.
And that has value, minus 1.
And this should be times d.
And the only value of
i that stayed was 1.
The only value of j
that stayed was 3.
And then only value of
k that stayed was 2.
So this says that d1,3,2 should
be equal to d1,3,2,
which I don't like, unless it's
supposed to be negative.
I did something wrong here.
Well, you see how easy
it is, even if it
didn't turn out right.
And the form of the tensor for
monoclinic crystal of symmetry
2, with a twofold access
parallel to x3, has as shown
in the lower left-hand corner
of the handout on symmetry
restrictions, it has eight
non-zero terms.
If you do the same thing for a
mirror plane perpendicular to
x3, you find that there
are 10 non-zero terms.
So we don't have the situation
where all of the point groups
that are able to show the
property within a given
crystal systems like monoclinic
have exactly the
same form of the property
tensor.
In fact, you'll notice a curious
correspondence between
the restrictions for symmetry
2 and symmetry m.
All the terms that are 0 in
symmetry 2 are non-zero in
symmetry m, and vice versa.
All the non-zero terms
in symmetry 2 are
0 in symmetry m.
And the reason for that is
simply that this is the form
of the direction cosine
scheme for symmetry 2.
The form of the direction cosine
scheme for symmetry m,
where the m is perpendicular to
x3, would have the form 1,
0, 0; 0, 1, 0; 0, 0, minus 1.
So ci,j, for a mirror plane
perpendicular to x3, is
exactly the negative of the
direction cosine scheme for a
twofold axis parallel to x3.
And since the number of
direction cosines is odd, this
means that everything that has
an equality between the
di,j,k's for m would have the
transformed element be the
negative of the original one
for 2, and vice versa.
So that's why there's this
complementary form of the
tensors for the two monoclinic
symmetries.
Point out a couple of curious
things in the tables.
You really have to go through
21 of the symmetries
independently.
And you find that some of them
do come out the same.
Symmetry 4 bar 3m and
symmetry 2:3 have
restrictions of the same form.
But for the most part--
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I know why
this is wrong.
PROFESSOR: Why is that wrong?
AUDIENCE: Because your notation
of d1,6 is in fact
not d1,3,2 but d1,2,1.
Since you have two same
indices, [? d3 ?]
and minus [? d1. ?]
PROFESSOR: OK.
d1,6; d1,6.
Ah, of course.
Of course. d1,2,6 is
the one up here.
And that's 1, 2 and 2,
1 for the strains.
OK.
Thank you.
So this is d1,1,2 plus d1,2,1.
And so we would have
1 by 1,k and 2,k.
1, 1, and 2.
And 1, 1, 1.
1,i; 1,j; and 2,j
for this one.
So we'd have c1,1 c1,1 c2,2. c
c1,1 is minus 1; c1,1 is minus
1; c2,2 is minus 1.
So d1,1,2 is minus d1,2,1, which
means they have to be
identically 0.
Thank you.
I'm sure nobody cares
at this point.
Very good.
OK.
Another curious thing that
happens is that for cubic
symmetry 4:3:2, it's acentric.
But every single modulus is 0.
And the reason, the explanation,
is there's so
many different transformations
which have to leave the tensor
invariant that the poor tensor
just can't do it.
It gives up, packs up, and goes
home, leaving all the
elements zero.
Just no way you can get all the
qualities to be satisfied.
Another curious result that I
point out for some of the
hexagonal symmetries for
symmetry 3:2, for symmetry
6:2:2, and for 3 over m and 6
bar 2m, all the elements of
the form d3, something
are identically 0.
Which says you simply cannot
create a polarization that has
a component P3.
You just cannot create a
polarization perpendicular to
the axis of high symmetry.
Yeah.
Got a question?
AUDIENCE: So all of the cubic
that has 4:3:2 symmetry or
[? 4:1:0 ?], that means
you can't get--
PROFESSOR: You just don't have
any piezoelectric effect, even
though the crystal is not
centrosymmetric, requiring
that all those transformations
leave the tensor invariant;
simultaneously, require that
everything has to be 0.
One final thing, and then I'm
running a little bit over.
But I'd like to go on to other
aspects of piezoelectricity
during the next hour.
Remember something that we've
shown and which I've asked you
to look into again on one of the
problem sets, and that is
that the trace of the strain
tensor gives you
the change in volume.
The first 3 by 3 blocks of this
tensor that we've been
looking at, were we to write
the elements of strain,
epsilon i,j, in terms of d--
epsilon j,k--
in terms of di,j,k times e sub
k, it is this block in here
which enters into the terms
epsilon 1,1; epsilon 2,2; and
epsilon 3,3.
These terms give you the
fractional change in volume.
And the elements that are
involved in the piezoelectric
matrix are these
terms in here.
So if all of those terms are 0,
it turns out that when you
apply a stress and look at the
electric field, or apply an
electric field and look at the
strain, if you apply a field
and all of those nine
terms are 0, you
cannot create a strain.
So there's no volume change.
There can be a strain,
but no volume change.
The only deformation you can
create is pure shear.
So if you drive a piezoelectric
oscillator with
an electric field, for those
property tensors for which
that first 3 by 3 block
are all zero,
the thing can shear--
in the water, for example--
but it can't pulse.
It can't have a volume change.
And if you were to create
a transducer for sonar
applications, what you would
want to do is to have
piezoelectric device which
expanded this way, to create a
sound wave going through
the water.
If it just goes back and forth,
it's going to slosh
back and forth in the water and
not create any sonic wave
that could be used in sonar.
Now that is true for elements
being identically 0.
It turns out it's also true for
elements such as 4 bar,
where two of those terms in
the 3 by 3 block are the
negative of one of the other.
These will also have
no volume change.
So that's another very curious
property of piezoelectric
response that follows from these
symmetry restrictions.
OK.
That's enough for our
first session.
When we come back, we'll
look at the converse
piezoelectric effect.
And we'll also look at
representation surfaces for
specific piezoelectric devices
and ask if it's possible for a
third-rank tensor to have a
representation surface that's
analogous to the representation
quadric for
second-rank tensors.
So I'm sure you'll all want to
come back and hear the answer
to that question.